it's a day these children will remember
all their lives for many it's the first
time aboard an aircraft but this plate
won't be taking off the flight to
nowhere is an airline with the
difference it offers passengers a taste
of flying without ever leaving the
ground many school children here are
poor the families cannot afford a real
ticket the passengers are treated to a
full in-flight experience they receive
modding cards safety briefings even
refreshments are served in born it's an
eye-opening experience ballet I've seen
planes in sky I used to think they were
really small but now I know they're
actually huge I now want to fly to
London I've heard there are beautiful
things to see the city some lucky
passengers even get to visit the cockpit
the man behind the project is Bahadur
and Gupta a retired aircraft engineer he
sold his land and bought the
decommissioned Airbus a300 back in 2003
for six hundred thousand rupees that's
about seven thousand euros a real
bargain he charges people according to
what they can afford as little as a few
Euro cents or even nothing at all for
the very poor I belong to a very small
village and I never expected I'll become
an engineer and then I'll be in the
airline and then people from my village
they used to say your toesies aircraft
and they were not able to see that route
so that was actually a basic idea and
basic motivation that I want to show
this aircraft or the poor people air
travel still remains a luxury for many
people in India for those who may never
get to take a flight this comes close to
the real thing without leaving the
ground and it's not the only place for
it in Delhi not far away a busy main
road that runs parallel to the runway of
Delhi's Internet
it's the perfect spot of the evening to
watch planes land
trees double ups trees
it's all about getting the right vantage
point for the poor migrant workers here
shelling out 4000 rupees or 50 euros for
a cheap flight ticket is beyond their
means it's my dream to someday take a
plane and fly to my village in Bihar but
that's only if I manage to scrape enough
money together for a ticket further on
Attaway we crossing regulars here swear
this is the closest you can get as the
turbo Jets take off
in my village the planes fly really high
up in the sky but from here you can see
them up close it's an amazing feeling
possibly passing we may not have the
money for a plane ticket but but that
doesn't stop us from dreaming about what
it must feel like to be up in the sky
back at the flight to know where
passengers simulate an evacuation to
finish the experience rarely has an
emergency situation seemed like so much
fun
[Music]